[Applause]
hello everyone I'm Jason Young
jn8607 on Discord you may have seen me
and uh you may know me as the Volkswagen
guy
um
I have a very good friend who tends to
go all in on technology Hobbies
um he got us into quadcopters back in
the day before they were popular he went
all in on home automation he's trying to
get us all to build combat robots which
I don't know if I'm going to do unless
we're going to get building facility to
do get out here
but back in 2018
he handed me an eon a giraffe and a gray
panda
and he said I bought this but I can't
make it work on my car he had like a 08
Acura something or other
but do you think this would work on that
Golf R you just bought because in the
repository there's this file called VW
mqb do you know what that is
and I'm like
no but I'm gonna find out
five years later
I'm on the stage of Comic-Con so as you
can see that one kind of spun out of
control
so
in my day job in my corporate life it's
a habit to introduce myself with a
couple of uh personal facts usually that
personal fact is
I drive my car with a cell phone but
that doesn't really move the needle in
this room
for obvious reasons and we're kind of
past cell phones so my random fact is
the 8607 is my Cisco ccie number
the guy in my Discord profile pic is a
famous actor that's played in an old
Volkswagen ad campaign
probably 20 years ago and I've had five
total strangers approach me in airports
restaurants whatever and tell me I look
like Tom Hanks I don't see it I don't
get it I love Tom Hanks I'm flattered
but it's just a thing that happened to
me so that's my random personal fact
So today we're going to talk about how
to Port cars
um
this will be
very generic I'm going to use some
examples that are drawn from a
Volkswagen world
but this is not a Volkswagen specific
talk
um we're going to start off and talk
about
is the car a good candidate this doesn't
mean we can know in advance if your car
will work you're going to have to go
kind of all the way through the process
to verify that but there's some red
flags that we look for
we'll talk about what you need for a Dev
environment
we'll talk about connecting to the car
for the first time reading data and
translating that into something that
openpilot can use
we'll talk about sending messages for
the first time finding the actuator
commands that you're
cars Factory Lane assist camera and ACC
radar use
and last we'll talk about the process of
upstreaming cars
so
three classes of cars here
it's a good sign if your car has Lane
keeping assist and adaptive cruise
control those are really minimums for
supporting open pilot on your car yeah
you can hack around it but it's not a
good open pilot experience if you don't
have adaptive cruise and Lane keeping
assist is a minimum and the other thing
is we want to make sure it uses standard
can or knfd networking
bad signs
some higher end cars don't use candle
use something called Flex rate and
Flex Ray is in a way that's hard to
explain actually I'm not qualified to
explain it is hard to split open pilot
in the middle of comma did a hackathon
type thing that actually made this work
on an Audi Q8 but I I think they decided
it was going to be a mess and hard to
bring to Market and didn't really
proceed with it it is difficult and
right now there's really no way on the
market to work with it
if there's Automotive ethernet in the
car that's starting to become common uh
in new vehicle designs
right now we don't have transceivers for
that it's something you can buy it's not
hard to get on ethernet itself the
trouble
with Automotive ethernet as
manufacturers refresh to that is it has
a strong tendency to come with secure
onboard communication
which is a euphemism for there's
cryptographic hashes on messages that
stop you from messing with things
flexray is just challenging to intercept
if your car has Seco c as unfortunately
Toyota and actually certain VW are
starting to have you actually have an
adversary someone's trying to stop you
from having fun uh and that's going to
be a little bit difficult so I think
both of those will be surmounted
eventually but they're going to be very
vehicle specific uh and they're not
something I'm personally working on and
that that's going to be task for someone
else
if your car doesn't have any of this
stuff you might actually have an easier
time there's
um
some folks that actually bolted a power
an electric power steering rack and a
bunch of microcontrollers and some other
things into a late 70s Volkswagen
Vanagon
um
now after that was done that Vanagon
kind of identifies as a Toyota Corolla
but
it works so in some ways
that car on the right is actually easier
than this car in the middle
so
let's say you have a car that's likely
to work in this case mine
or whatever car that you might have and
I want to be clear that
what I'm talking about here today is
actually not that hard to do
um
if you can spell Linux and SSH you can
go through these Journeys that I've gone
through it used to be a lot harder than
it was but it's gotten pretty easy so
first thing workstation something
running Ubuntu VMware or WSL is fine I'm
about half and half uh bare metal Ubuntu
when I'm working from home uh this
laptop running Windows 11 I do the other
half on under wsl2
next thing you need is a comma three I
missed a memo on it not being a Devi kit
anymore
so comma 3 or 3x and when you order it
you'll order it with a developer harness
which I'll show you in just a moment
the return window for these guys is
normally 30 days I'm not sure what the
process is but if you're working on a
new car port they will give you a little
bit of extra time and then you'll need a
few basic tools you'll need a diagnostic
tool for your car it's a must you're
going to tick off your car during this
process and you'll need to be able to
clear faults and you'll need some
visibility into what's going on and
you'll need some other Basics multimeter
wire cutters crimper Etc
so
when you order from the comma store
and you get a developer harness that's
what it'll look like it looks like
any other harness adapter that they sell
you but there's no ends on it yet
you get to put the ends on it because
whatever ends that it needs the
connector shells and the terminals are
going to be unique to your car
you can figure that out by looking at
the connector cars on your car they'll
usually be a part number on it somewhere
um the one end will usually be easy to
find the other end
is sometimes rough because that's not
something the manufacturer ever has to
supply
in a harness form it's always built into
the camera in a pinch during development
you can make do with generic cart Edge
pin headers but
one way or another you need to take that
and adapt it to your car
and this is how you do it
every auto manufacturer in the US and in
really worldwide will have some way for
you to get access to repair info it's
not going to be free you generally have
to pay for it if you go to irwin.vw.com
as an example but you can do this for
any auto manufacturer you can get a
wiring diagram for any given car
and that'll
you can't really read this and you don't
have to but that will tell you
how your camera is wired up what's on
what pin
you take that together with commas open
harness wiring diagram and that'll tell
you where you need to put constant power
ignition switch power ground can high
can low and optional second can
and any pass-throughs that you need for
like a camera heater or or a fusion bus
so on and so forth
so
let's assume we've made that harness
and we've connected to our connected to
our car
this is what we need to figure out for
openpilot to work this is a subset of
what goes into car state we need to know
how fast the wheels are turning what the
steering angle is what gear you're in
all that good stuff and in order to
learn that we look at Cabana
um I promise the next slides will be
easier to read I wanted you to see the
whole window this time but
what you're looking at right now is a
pile of numbers and this looks
intimidating
but
it'll clarify pretty soon by the way
before I forget
um
this tool was made by another comma
external contributor named Dean Lee I
think Adib asked him one day hey do you
want to do something about Cabana
because the web Cabana is getting really
crusty and then you just bang this tool
out in like a couple of weeks and has
been growing it from there and it is a
game changer for reverse engineering can
networks so Dean Lee if you're seeing
this you're the man we love you
[Music]
[Applause]
so
I'm not going to step through every
single one of those signals I'm going to
take you through three examples of some
of the more complex ones and a couple
tricks of how to find them
so Cabana the deanley wrote will show
you
and highlight bits that are changing to
find wheel speeds you're looking for
four signals that scale with how fast
the car is moving they stand still when
the car is parked and they move
linearly
when the car is driving so somewhere in
that pile of numbers
is Cabana is going to highlight ones
that change in about the same way
times four
so we now know four wheel speeds but
where do they go
get in your car you'll take a test drive
in a parking lot
set your parking brake
and then take off from a stop drive a
figure eight stop and look at your logs
front and back will identify themselves
because
when your parking brake is set and
you're driving a front-wheel drive car
as most folks are particularly the
parking brake set the front wheels will
start rolling first so now you know
front and back
when you drive that figure eight
the outside Wheels
will turn faster
so
as we're making this sweeping tight
right turn the outside wheel
is turning faster
and that tells us left and right so now
we have front back left right we know
where all the wheels are
next you'll do a simple test log for gas
and brake usually I press the gas three
times press the brake three times
take it in look at it
the accelerator
will have a curve that goes up and down
it's pretty obvious it's not an on and
off it's a you'll find a percentage
somewhere you may need to scale it
you'll find a similar signal for brake
pressure that'll be some sort of curve
and it'll match when you're pressing the
brake and by the way there's some
features within Cabana that you can say
for all those signal changes that it's
highlighting
you can say kind of freeze those and
clear those for this little 10 second
time window and just show me the ones
that changed within there
and that'll start making things like
this pop out
and then it's nice to find a signal for
brake pressed
um
you can do that in a pinch by just
showing brake pressure above one but
that doesn't work for all cars sometimes
the Signal's a little noisy this ends up
being the source of a lot of bugs
comma chased a lot of these out on a
deep and chain we're doing improved
testing for cars and chasing down
controls mismatches and so forth brake
pressed can come from a lot of sources
there'll be a switch on the brake pedal
often there's redundant switches so you
may be seeing those you may be seeing
something from the ABS controller that
says break pressure over a certain
threshold and those are all good but you
might also be seeing something that says
open the brake shift interlock
or if you're driving
this might actually be a brake light
signal which sounds cool until you
remember that your ACC when it's slowing
down also fires off the brake lights so
you want to make go ahead and flag all
the signals that are potentially brake
pressed but come back and look at it and
make sure it's actually only flogging
the ones that the driver presses in
now for steering inputs I've got a
particular way that I like to do this
get in the car
start it up
and
you'll turn the wheel to 45 90 180
full lock and hold it
let go
and then turn it back to 0 45 90.
and that gives you a steering angle
unfortunately my laser pointer doesn't
show up really well against this screen
that'll give you your steering angle
and the scaling since when you turn to
45 you know the value you should get is
45 90 180. sometimes you have to watch
this on Progressive ratio variable
steering racks but
this one happens to be pretty easy so
that'll give you
the steering angle the direction if it's
separate sometimes it's combined in an
assigned value sometimes it's separate
in this case it's separate it'll also
give you the amount of driver input
torque this is important for torque
blending as you're driving with open
pilot so that open pilot can back off
the guidance that it's giving you if the
driver is providing input and also so it
knows which way you're nudging for
desire inputs like Lane changes
so
it'll show you here
as we're steering that EPS link moment
it'll show you that we're providing some
input and then high input
when we're holding it at lock it'll go
to zero
when you release and you'll see that the
direction sign is different because
as we're turning the wheel back
we're providing pressure torque going
left even though the total steering
angle is still right we haven't crossed
zero yet so with that simple test
procedure that gets you all the scaling
that you need all the directions that
you need
so we take that
plug it in with cabana and that outputs
a DBC which
goes into an open Pilot Car State and
tells open pilot everything that it
needs to know about what your car is
doing how fast you're going where the
wheel is
etc etc
there's a lot more signals you'll need
to hunt down eventually but those
examples should kind of show you how to
use Cabana
the next thing we do is figure out how
to send messages
there's very few that we want to send
the ones that we do want to send are the
factory Lane keeping assist messages and
we're just talking about lateral for now
because I have 20 minutes to get through
this
this is usually from the factory camera
it's usually a torque signal they're
usually sending a command saying
turn the wheel this hard in this
direction
it's not a direct command to follow this
Lane whatever the camera is saying turn
the steering wheel this hard
sometimes the camera does send an angle
I think Tesla does this I think Nissan
does this I haven't looked lately
um
recently we had one come up that sent a
path curvature uh I know this drove
Cameron nuts for a while when I was
bringing Ford on board
but he got that figured out uh had to do
some clever reverse engineering to turn
that into something open pilot could use
so take note of what your factory camera
does
to actually control your car what type
of signal it sends and what the maximums
are
and then we teach open pilot to do that
in order for the car to actually pay
attention to this message we got to talk
about payload checksums encounters
um
you may notice and most are all the
messages that your car sends there's a
counter
there's some field somewhere that just
rolls over and over and over it counts
up one every frame sometimes it's two
bits sometimes it's four bits all the VW
ones happen to be four uh some of their
makes are two
you'll also see a payload checksum of
some form and a lot of messages
this can come in the form of literally a
checksum add up all the byte values and
take the remainder sometimes it's an xor
over the message payload
um sometimes it's an actual CRC
in the case of Volkswagen happens to be
a strangely modified CRC that took
forever to figure out
um
in some cars it's completely random I've
seen the algorithm for Chrysler and I'd
have no idea what they're doing there
but somebody figured it out
the key thing that you want to look for
and hope for is if you see on the left
side of the checksum there
if the message payload Remains the Same
and you get the same checksum for that
every time
there's something there that you can
replicate
and you just have to figure it out and
there's tools for that now there's a
tool called CRC beagle that you can get
off GitHub that you feed it uh
whatever byte value you're getting and
this payload and it will figure out it
will may not figure out completely
automatically but it'll do a lot of The
Drudge work that I had to do manually
five years ago
if on the other hand you see randomness
if the payload and
other values aren't repeating cyclically
if it's fully random
you might be having a bad day because
that might be a cryptographic hash you
might have run into secoc
if that's the case you you might be
leveraging that return policy let's hope
we don't see a ton of that but that's
what to look for
so let's assume we've got the steering
message figured out
Cabana is going to write out that DBC
for you
you're going to go into open pilot and
have the car controller actually send
out a torque command and by the way you
actually don't have to take care of
figuring out
at no point you have to worry about
where the car is in a lane what
direction to go how to turn the wheel
open pilot takes care of all the path
planning for you and it already has a
built-in controller for how much we want
to turn the wheel you just have to kind
of figure out you have to develop that
Rosetta Stone of
here's how to express a tour command of
the car
and that is what we want to do I'm going
to send a torque command if with that
direction and some match some other
stock values that were used and in this
case deeper levels of the open DBC
Library are handling the checksum
encounter for us
and that takes us to
what is hopefully good news
this picture was taken
at an early icky January morning in 2019
on the first day I made that thing work
let me tell you that was a good day
that was a fight to make that work I I
think it took me something on the order
of three months
and that was with several people helping
me and providing hints
um
and there were still a ton of time in
the driver's seat looking at tmux fixing
typos oh my God I can't believe I made
another typo controls crashed again wait
why hasn't the device starting anymore
it's
back in the day open pilot was a lot
less testable verifiable that
infrastructure that we have today didn't
fully exist yet
but once you get it running
that first time that you feel open pilot
engage and provide some guidance to the
wheel
you're having a pretty good day
if your car makes it an entire minute
down the road and preferably more like
10 minutes you're having a real good day
but
sometimes you can get all the way into
this process and find out you've got a
lockout
and that's bad news
sometimes there's workarounds for that
but every car that has a modern level 2
Adas system
will not let the driver go hands off
indefinitely
the difference is
who enforces that
some manufacturers drive that entirely
from the camera
and if it's the camera that's deciding
whether there's driver input
and whether to disengage openpilot can
replace that
a few manufacturers I think some
varieties of Mazda
um
not recalling others off hand but
old Ford okay
sometimes that 15 or 30 second lockout
is enforced on the eps
in that case
um
well that's a bummer
sometimes there's workarounds there's
things you can play with don't give up
immediately
reach out for help but it's not a great
sign if it consistently breaks after the
same number of seconds but hopefully you
get down the road
and if you do that's fantastic you've
got a lot of cleanup and quality work to
do after that to make it good
don't worry if it doesn't drive well at
that point you can fix that as long as
it open pilot can take control
for five or ten minutes
this is going to work so
that was my day in 2019.
this was Wednesday
what you're seeing here is the next
generation of mqb called mqb Evo this is
a 22 2022 GTI
we rented earlier this week
uh we modified a harness that's not
unlike one of the ones we use on VW
right now we moved a couple of pins
around there actually is Automotive
ethernet in this car but we don't care
about it it's used as a replacement for
the fusion bus between the camera and
the radar but we just pass it through
don't listen to it the stuff we do care
about is can FD and they rototilled some
of the messages and we had to go through
a process of reverse engineering again
but openpile is a very different product
today
the carports have been massively cleaned
up and standardized and templated
there's CI tests that mean you can take
a log and play it back through controls
and verify that everything works the way
you think it should and doesn't crash
before you get up from your desk you're
not doing this from the driver's seat
anymore you have tests that will check
all this stuff out
and then
new Cabana
will help you out with this
and
the whole thing ends up being a lot
easier and faster
last time this took three months this
time we had it done in nine hours
to be clear it's not Upstream yet this
is probably the worst possible week to
ask a div and Shane to look at
upstreaming a PR
but it's in progress
so guidelines for upstreaming
it needs to be safe it needs to comply
with all the guidelines that Adib and
the rest of the open pilot team laid out
earlier today needs to be passing tests
you need to verify all the checksums
encounters not only for sending but also
for receiving
and you need to make sure if you're
using stock ICC that open pilot can
reject engagements uh if there's
something wrong
then it needs to be supportable it needs
to work like other open pilot cars and
that means torque blending that's one of
the reasons Tesla isn't listed is
officially supported because the
steering API doesn't work quite like we
want
there needs to be no visible faults it
needs to drive in a way that
would be acceptable for a person and if
there are faults you need to log them
and upload them so they can be analyzed
later
this comes into play as part of all the
work that the open pilot team has done
to improve quality and mtbf and
autopilot to the point where the last
couple of times that the open pilot team
has had me look at routes
that experienced faults we tracked them
back to a bug in the car
um one of them was a retrofit that
somebody had retrofitted ACC to the car
didn't have it from the factory and
they'd use the wrong software the other
one was genuinely software bug in the
ECU a certain model here of Atlas had
engine ECU firmware that if you did the
wrong thing in wrong order with remote
start you wouldn't have cruise control
for the next start
so you want to get to the point where
everything works and then
it needs to be actually marketable in
order for it to be upstream and actually
appear on comma's website and and Shop
you got to figure out how to make that
harness manufacturable means you got to
find the other connectors on the other
end it needs to be something somebody
can reasonably install
and it needs to be fully plug fully Plug
and Play fully reversible it needs to
work like
uh the open pilot experience and other
cars because it's one thing when you are
working on your own car but when this is
upstream and in a store
it's not you that's taking the support
calls or the rmas or the angry emails
it's those guys so it needs to be dialed
in in order for it to appear for actual
sale to actual customers
so
that's my talk uh that's
[Applause]